what if you didn't leave your bathtub  for a week  well first thing is you'd start to  notice bubbles forming on your skin  these bubbles would continue to form the  longer you're in the bath creating  bubble-filled skin all over your body as  time goes on they'll slowly fester and  grow bigger  this will keep happening until a few  days into your bath marathon when they  begin to burst  and if you haven't been disposing of  your waste you'd be sitting in a pool  full of fecal matter with open sores all  over your body  maybe you'd realize that these sores  have been distracting you from something  else that's happening  your bath is getting dangerously cold  luckily it won't kill you as the  temperatures just aren't low enough  but by the end of the week you'd  definitely be in the hospital  so have you ever wondered